so the three things I wanna tell you
about this evening the first one is I'm
going to
bolused now yeah that's
big we're impressed so that means a
tightrope walker because a lot of you
people actually all of you are somehow
are the are going to create things in
your life so a fine ambulance is like a
type of tightrope walker okay
so the first word I learned please give
me claps for this new word that I've got
Gail okay however I look at it in its
eventual analysis my life has centered
around my creativity
I have assimilated the world through
creative expression and return the world
has experienced me hopefully I've grown
to understand that on one hand the world
will always uphold creativity as the
most honest feeling possible on the
other hand the portents of fame the
glitz the glamour the wealth that arise
from this very recognition of creativity
will always be questioned why do we do
that because sometimes it allows us to
feel better in the creator and sometimes
it fills a void within us that comes
about by being in awe of his or her
creation either way it enables us to
quantify his or her engagement
engagement with the world around him I
am an actor my life is a testament to
this duality George Burns said their
acting is all about honesty if you can
figure it made and he couldn't have
defined it better honest and fake yes
that's what I feel as a creative person
all the time let me tell you my
schizophrenia creative expression comes
from the deepest experience of the
artist himself a good artist cannot be
separate from his creation good art is
honest at a man may be an artist a
writer a sculptor an actor or a totem
pole Carver whatever he is if what he
creates is true to himself it becomes a
vivid testimonial to human creativity if
it lacks honesty it is entire its entire
premise is a waste at the same time and
quite paradoxically a man becomes
distinct from his creation from the
moment it is placed in the public domain
it no longer even belongs to him so it
comes from your gut and it is put out
there for others to accept it or throw
it in the gutter